what's the value
what's the hope what's the power of
conversation here
if you could sit down with vladimir
putin and have a conversation
versus bullets human exchange words
is there hope for those and if so what
would you talk about what would you ask
him
well henry kissinger
you alluded to his op-ed he's had many
private meetings with president putin
over over a long time
and
president biden
the previous presidents
secretaries of state
officials below secretary of state
the head of the cia
evidently met with president putin
in the fall
when
he was massing the troops on the border
before he invaded
and we we sent the head of the cia and
putin received him
somebody he evidently respects or was at
least willing to meet
unlike other members of the
administration
so a lot of people are talking to him in
some form or another
for the 22 years he's been in power
and i'm not sure it's had
what i would call
their desired effect
well the nature of the conversation is
interesting too and also the timing
which is post february 22nd is a
different
time and also another aspect
uh which oliver stone mentioned
interestingly
that there's something about covid and
the pandemic that creates isolation the
distancing it's such a silly little
nuanced thing
but maybe it's actually
has a profound impact on the human being
the human mind of vladimir putin that
there is something about an in-person
meeting and not across a table that's
far too large yes but sort of the
intimacy of one human wants
human-to-human in-person conversation
that
there's something distinctly powerful
about that reminder that
that
as putin says in the narrative and the
propaganda that we're all one people
there is truth to that that this
entirety of humanity yes
white people and you kind of reminded by
that
when you're sitting together
people who have
sat across the table from him
whether at 30 yards or
at three
have remarked upon this feeling of
isolation has that has affected him the
pandemic
i think there must be something to that
if if several people
who've been in the room with him are
remarking on it
everybody that i know and i've been able
to talk to who's had a meeting with him
in the past 10 years
including
henry kissinger the former secretary of
state
has said that putin spends a lot of time
enumerating his grievances
he goes through a monologue of his
grievances
and then the west did this and then the
west lied to us about that
and then the west cheated us on this
and so it's not the conversation
that you're encouraging of common
humanity
it's that roiling resentment volcano
that's just exploding and exploding the
resentment
and and by the time
he gets through the monologue
of the grievances
the time or the meeting is is expired or
or overtime
that's a brilliant statement but that's
where the skill of conversation comes in
like when you're facing a bull with a
red cloth
you have to learn how to avoid the long
list of grievances and get to the
humanity
that's that's a really important it's a
skill for sure it's a skill and it's the
highest level skill of a diplomat
to be able to reach some type of common
understanding when interests and and
worldviews clash so much
but here's your challenge lex
your challenge is
russia wants to impose
a closed sphere of influence
on its neighbors
it wants to dictate
what its neighbors can and can't do
it wants to exert influence not by the
power of its example
not by the freedom of its people
not by the dynamism of its diversified
economy
but it wants to exert influence just
because it deserves that just because
it's a great power
just because
and on and on and on
it's a civilization unto itself
and it wants that and we can't give that
the reason that russia was not
integrated into the west was not for
lack of trying
it was because
russia ultimately spurned the
integration because it was about what
terms the integration would come on
would you come into the west and observe
western rules
and be another country
meaning just another country
there's
poland and there's austria
and there's
little tiny monaco and there's and
there's russia
and you're just one of those countries
and russia's answer to that was no
we're not just one of those countries
we need special rules
we need special conditions
we'll integrate but only as a special
country meaning
like at the u.n
where all countries are sovereign all
countries are members but russia has a
veto
on what countries can and can't do
those were the terms
on which they were willing to integrate
and those were the terms that no leader
of a western country or the united
states
or the g7
or fill in the blank can grant to russia
it's very well known that vladimir putin
was one of the first maybe the first
person first leader
foreign leader to call president bush
after the 9 11
tragedy
they didn't connect right away
president bush was not in washington and
but eventually they did speak
he condemned the terrorist attack he
offered russian support
which he delivered on
the use of some russian logistics for
our afghanistan
operations
and a lot of people point to that and
they say there it is russia wanted to
cooperate
and
did cooperate and we spurned them
or we failed to appreciate
russia's cooperation
and so therefore russia was cheated or
russia was lied to or russia's
grievances are legitimate
but here's the problem with that
argument lex
in exchange for that support vladimir
putin
asked in return from president bush
for a free hand in the former soviet
space that closed hierarchical sphere of
influence
where russia would exert influence
coercively
over countries that were sovereign
and no american president
could grant that and president bush was
right he said no
and so
the attempted cooperation blew up
you